what do you guys think of the whole like
pickup artists have you have you heard
of like the whole pickup artist
Community there's a community for that
YouTubers who are pickup artist there's
also a guy who's married who's a pickup
artist and there's one video where he
made his wife watch his videos with him
are you serious it was the most it was
the most painful video I've ever seen in
my life what's wrong with people um yeah
it was uh I think Charlie did a video
about it and it was a was horrible to
watch Wait so so explain this like
pickup artist Community to me so it's a
community of men basically of men uh
it's it's kind of an offshoot of let's
say the guru community that I think
there's that's like you know they have
like you have like the financial Bros
you have the way to a woman yeah now you
have like the now you have like the pck
like now you have like the pickup artist
Community which is kind of that same
kind of Guru structure but for lonely
guys who want to learn how do they just
like teach you pickup lines they no they
teach you how to be aggressive towards
women normally these dudes are just
aggressive they're just and you know I
if you cast women love that if you cast
the net out wide enough you're bound to
have some success right that's that's I
I want to see a pickup artist in that
community that just like teaches dudes
like just terrible pickup lines that
just never work all of them all of them
do that a lot of are you from Tennessee
you're the only 10 I see lot of them are
like hey buy my course you know yeah a
lot of them are just like here uh let me
show you how to pick up 10 and get a get
a numbered 90% success rate or something
like that I call this the infinite [__]
glitch a lot of these guys who are
making these videos are conventionally
very attractive so youve already the the
easiest thing that you can do to
increase your chance of Landing a date
or a pickup is be [__] hot which most
of us aren't you know that's not how it
how it works so you know the reason why
these [__] shitty corn if a if a if a
guy who was not attractive and a guy
who's very attractive said the same
cheesy pickup line there's going to be
two very different results I need to see
a pickup artist who is oh go then I'll
be more convinced it's called $10 to
$500 mon so what you want to do is swipe
crazy no I I get Okay the reason I'm
bringing this up right is because I want
to play Devil's Advocate right okay
because you think men need it huh we
need this I think Okay I uh I I guess
I've never talked about this before but
you need it huh you needed a pck artist
in your darkest hour hell yeah I
did I um okay so like I think the whole
like epidemic pandemic or whatever of
like the loneliness like especially
lonely men I think I think I think a big
problem is that a lot of guys who let's
say are in the same situation as you
know marrying a DS or getting attracted
to or getting very very addicted to porn
or getting uh having so much emotional
connection to fictional girls or or like
pay to win there's so many different
ways to offset your loneliness because
at the end of the day it's easier to do
that than it is to learn how to not be
lonely right and there is there was like
there was like literally a book that
changed my life uh and it was called the
game by Neil Strauss okay and it is
literally a book about some like uh uh
an author uh a writer who found himself
in the pickup artist Community uh and I
believe he's done a lot of like [__]
terrible things now I I don't know what
he's done nowadays I know he he doesn't
have the best kind of like reputation
now but at that time when I was about 16
17 when I discovered this book um seeing
this like story told about the whole
pickup artist community and uh all the
techniques that they use and everything
like that what I got out of it was at
the time I was just a [__] lonely ass
guy who did not know how to socialize
and reading that book it didn't make me
[__] aggressive towards girls or
anything like that it just gave me some
like training wheels to work with to
overcome what kind of tips do you feel
helped you kind of Concepts uh just kind
of like ice breakers to like how do you
open up a conversation without coming
off sound creepy yeah yeah how do you
open up a conversation and not sound
like a complete [__] or a complete
creep cuz I didn't [__] know how to
do that [__] Japan yeah that's the
thing needs that's the thing and like I
I started off like my university life
kind of like going around this some of
like the things that I had read from
this book not as like a complete Bible
but just as a I don't know what to do in
this situation so let me just follow the
[__] flowchart of social interaction
to see to give me like the training
wheels and then from that after I just
experienced the real world that's what
gave me the training wheels to really
learn how to socialize so like I [__]
empath with a lot of lonely guys out
there because I was [__] that I I was
that guy you know I did not know how to
go out basical question then if the $500
Tinder thing had come out when you were
in that lonely period when you were 16
17 would you assuming I was rich
assuming you had infinite money glitch
would you have done it [__] no [__]
no it's like pain for po I'm asking God
I don't know loneliness is [__]
painful man pain that's why I'm asking
this hypothetical hypothetically
I would like to say that if I were let's
say rich but I was [__] lonely [__]
you could afford it yeah if I could
afford it I would like to think I was a
better I would be a better man but I've
been in some like I've I've been in some
[__] dark places in my life I cannot
hold my hand on heart say yeah I'm guys
I I would be above this [__] you know I
I would be above all of the [__]
things that we clown on because holy
[__] there is nothing more like
depressing than being starved of human
connection and if you have no one to
[__] judge you on your actions what
the [__] are you going to care about
right that's true that's exactly what
this is marketed when I see a lot of
these guys who get very angry online or
very um what's the word um jaded jaded
like interacting normally with men
approaching women yeah it's like 90% of
the time when I when I see these dudes
who who like feel burned and I you know
for whatever reason you can see how they
interact with women you're like oh my
God you're just you just approached a
random woman and just started trying to
like you you didn't come into this with
the same level of Interest like you
immediately are way more into this
person than than they are into you and
you got to recognize that energy
difference you got to recognize that
like you're on a different level here
and you one you flat out just shouldn't
approach random people a lot of the time
it doesn't work that's not how life
works you cannot just see someone who's
attractive and approach them sure for
some people it might work occasionally
but most people don't [__] do that
which is why I don't get in Japan the
whole Numa culture what's the what's the
num culture n it's basically like pickup
artists but in Japan but like you see if
you go to like shio Shinjuku any like
big city late at night you'll see these
like pretty young looking dudes like
probably you know in their 20s just
[__] walking up to women and being
like Ona Ona you want to you want to go
hang out do you want to go play I'm like
no you [__] creepo like no no woman
with any self-respect is going to be
like oh yes random creepy dude that I
have no idea about I'm going to go along
and [__] hang out with you like and
I'm like I look at these guys like and
they doing it like in inside trains and
like at the train station out in the
street in stores and stuff like that and
I'm like when does that ever work
especially in a country like Japan where
stranger friendliness is close to zero
yeah ex I'm like what are you doing
you're wasting your time and you're
making s look like an idot I think a lot
of dudes don't know when to quit and
that's a really really important thing
when you're talking to someone is
knowing when you're like you've clearly
I'm inconvenience inconvenience or
you've gone too far or maybe you're
making someone slightly uncomfortable
you can tell they not interested yeah
and that's okay if someone's not
interested in talking to you that is a
human thing that everyone is entitled to
plenty of fish in the sea bro don't
worry well this is why people get so
annoyed even if it's like friendship
it's like you are not entitled to
someone's friendship you're not entitled
to someone's time you're not entitled to
someone's capacity emotion for sure and
it gets very I get really frustrated
when I see this online when dudes are
like oh that dead [__] woman didn't
want to talk to me it's like well yeah
she didn't have to you approach you
don't she doesn't know you anything you
are not entitled to this no one is
entitled and it is it is a very
attractive trait to be like ah this
person is clearly not vibing with me I'm
going to remove myself from the
situation because I'm clearly not very
welcome in the situation just get out of
it and that's one of the most
beneficials you can do as a human being
is being able to read that energy and
being like okay I'm clearly you're
saving their time and you're saving your
own time I'm clearly like I'm not I'm
done here like this is like and it's
okay you didn't [__] up yeah it's fine
anything you don't have to be friends
with everyone you didn't it's it's not a
slide on you you are take it don't
[__] get let your pride get in the
way it's okay to sometimes like not be
in the correct Vibe sure I I think I
think honestly a lot of a lot of the
example of these guys Unfortunately they
just has they just have not had the
right role model to like teach them what
the boundaries are what's like
acceptable or or like not acceptable
because a lot of people are [__]
lonely but not everyone who's lonely is
also an [__] and doesn't know what
boundaries are right and uh yeah it's
just minority that are these [__]
yeah unfortunately it's the most vocal
and the ones that get a lot of attention
I mean it's not just that it's just like
there's there's a lot of [__] you
see on especially like not just like
pickup artists but what like what was
the latest thing like [__] door to
door salesman and [__] like that as well
wait what door to door salesmen are
[__] floating they're back now on Tik
Tok yeah they're back selling like solar
panels or other stuff and and like
there's dudes who are like doing do not
do not leave the property unless you
have asked eight times at that door
that's harassment yeah absolutely
absolutely is [__] yeah these people
it's like they're just like they're like
the the concept is and this happens in
relationships or sales or whatever it is
like overwhelms someone to the extent
where they physically they don't know
what else to do other than to Cave into
what you say yeah uh and and that's like
the whole concept behind all of these or
they be pickups oror salesman should be
so intense so ass holy that they have
they like they feel the only recourse is
to then agree to whatever is the [__]
you're trying to do like okay fine fine
[__] it I'll buy a [__] solar panels
[__] off yeah um it's it's insane what
the culture is like yeah again probably
someone selling a course on how to
[__] sake why why are there so many
people selling courses cuz courses it's
easy to do courses are a fantastic way
of milking someone for money you can be
like buep one byep two yeah oh you're
nearly at the best club right now you're
nearly at the top TI it's a it's a trick
is all the time [__] look at look at
religion you know there's a a very very
famous religion that I w't say we don't
want to get season Tois but that always
does it that that does this they're like
oh but you need to pay $50,000 for the
reading material let's go to the next
level yeah courses are easy for a lot of
people because you're making a profit
without actually delivering or selling
anything physical Lear they learn from
the best universities at the end of the
day sell the books the $200 is the
biggest [__] scam of all time aside
from load themselves which is what you
do read another book nope this is the
only book you can read what if we uh can
what if we just pirate the book can you
can you do that so wait were you guys
forced to buy certain textbooks yeah so
yeah but I got in trouble one time did I
tell you about this I think I might have
mentioned on the podcast I had a I had
my friend bought the book and I asked
for it and I printed off all the sheets
that I was using and I took them into
the exam and they told me I couldn't
have it cuz it wasn't the official book
and I'm like it's the book it's just in
a really shitty format they were like
you have to buy the book and I was like
oh because my course buy the [__]
book my you were you were forced to I
think we only maybe had like two text
books for the entire 3 and a half years
old was there and if you didn't buy it
they were kind of just like I just go
and buy it eventually but like they
weren't like anal about they had this we
so we did engineering and one of the
most important things of engineering was
the um it was the uh like the thermal
capacity of each material and they they
would they would have a book that they
would release each year with like the
properties of the materials and mainly
it was the thermal capacity it was MH um
and every year they would update it and
I and I I I I was curious I was like
what's the difference and between two
years it was like three materials have
been slightly updated because they had
better readings but it was like I don't
feel like this is any bearing on my exam
like I don't think that I should be
forced to buy the new version every year
[__] you yeah buy the new [__]
version I didn't have much money I'm not
paying $200 for a book no [__] way
yeah it's pretty
absurd yeah I'm I'm trying of
remembering how cuz I didn't have to buy
one I had to buy four or five I think
the main one but they they try to get me
to buy other stuff too I was like I'm
I'm not buying that [__] [__] I fell for
that [__] man and I I use one of those
textbooks I think and the rest um I kind
of I'm trying to remember how how did I
how did I learn did one piece is great
it really taught me a lot about pirating
and being a pirate and I think that I
found that very useful there is such
thing as a good you know I think that
one piece is a lot of call messages that
I took to my university
is H you
know um don't have a p very
bad but uh what was I going to say do
you think you learned [__] in University
I learned what I didn't want to learn
the thing I I I always tell people I'm
like the most valuable thing you can
learn sometimes is learning what you
don't want in life what you you know
categorically you don't want I I
wouldn't have started YouTube if it
wasn't for the stuff I learned you cuz I
learned video editing at Uni well I
didn't learn that I [__] Le to learn
the hard way you learn video editing in
University [__] lucky I learned it
myself [__] Sony Vegas Sony Vegas and
it was all [__] Cod tutorials all the
time we had we had final Cod and like we
were learning video editing for one of
our courses and that's when I got
interested in making videos what what
did you learn in video
editing well I mean it was basically
just like cut guys well yeah honestly
like it was it was it was it was a great
way to get my foot in the door but like
obviously the rest of the [__] I had to
kind of experiment learn myself but
before then like you'd open up final I'm
like I don't know what the [__] I'm
looking at it's too much [__] but like I
learned like very simple just like you
know cut uh you know simple effects all
that kind of stuff to like make it look
a color correction all that kind of
stuff and then the rest of it was just
like okay I'll just teach myself soul